Is there water down there? (kid: yep) Perfect.
(fills the bag with water)
(kid: Can I be in your video?) Sure just sit down on that rock down there.
The car is coming now
Hey everybody off the road!
Okay, sit down on that rock there
(kid: on this one?) Yep, that's perfect. Let's see if I can get this going nope  yeah, sit down on all the way to the back
trying  to find focal point
*wood smokes*
(kid: Look at that! It's almost gonna start a fire.) That's right buddy
It has a hole in it. [oh] you're right. Thanks for telling me that ah
It's a drop
Dad it's dripping! I know I'm gonna try [make] sure it doesn't get on my fire
Okay, you gotta make sure it doesn't get on my fire
Whoa look at that?
It's a it's a water bomb
Don't worry. That's still going just don't touch it
[just] watch it. Okay
Don't touch it. Just watch it and [see] if it keeps smoking. I'm [gonna] go get another baggie of water
Hey guys, that's meg
Okay part two hey guys
Look, it's still going Dad. I hope that thing dosent do
That again. Thanks, buddy. I hope so too, but that's still smoldering pretty well
[kid yelling]
Fire, there's a fire starting
guys that looks like
(flips wood to transfer coals into sticks)
Hey guys, what's up?
Hey guys, hey guys one more blow
Here we go. Can I go [got] [my] dog come now?
Wow, a little bit
[kid singing]
Hi  did you get a hot dog? Oh you had them already for that didn't ya?
[well], you guys sure have been patient
Can I do this no is that [okay]? Yeah?
Can I cook one now?
Fire with the ziplock Baggie guys yeah daddy. yeah daddy!
uh no not all of them
What happened about stickers at work?
Mmm. Don't burn it
Do you light yours on fire?
No, one's taking Murray. Oh
You're so polite. Thank you. I'll take it out
Well your guys hot dogs were looking good already um because you up there for that camera right there, okay, okay?
[I'll] go get the bun
Yeah, once you go grab the buns buddy
I'll put yours on this stick after I finished roasting Jaemin's okay, okay?
This one's yours honey
We open one of those buns up for anybody?
, you can eat your hot dog. Do you want to on a bun like his? Yeah, okay
Come over here um
Yeah, this one's reese's. How you doing ray good
mum
No, it's good
Okay, yours is ready for a bun  when you ready for it. Is mine ready for a bun?
You want yours like that?